hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
I'm very excited to get into this game
but I forgot that I was at the loading
screen before so I don't think we've
missed anything here I loaded up the
game saw that we were going into a
cutscene but I'm pretty sure everything
is still kosher right now we're still on
our way into the game exactly where we
left off because we just jumped into the
river to try to get away from the people
on the bridge so that we can go into
this crazy-ass lighthouse and do
something or others now what I decided
to do differently from the last one is
that I'm not playing with a mouse and
keyboard so that I will hopefully be
able to aim better Oh
so either way this is gonna be a lot
more interesting hopefully and a lot of
people out there we're telling me in the
last episode that I need to break the
boxes when I see them saamana break them
to my heart's content and actually this
is a little bit better with the mouse
and keyboard it's still a little wonky
it's like the original dead space when I
played that the controls were intended
to be for controllers and it made things
a bit more panicked because it wasn't
easy to do which is a good thing because
it makes it a bit more stressful when
you're playing the game and thinks
you're going wonky but then again all
the buttons are gonna be different from
what they were so it's gonna take me a
little bit of getting used to but it
should be better in the long run so here
we go oh no no no no no no don't do that
how do i how do I get back to melee oh
god bear with me oh please there we go f
is melee I guess so Q is flashlight
oh okay I was like what the hell is that
noise okay so they're all up there
they're wandering on their way having a
little parade back to where they were
conformed but I wanted to mention
something that I mentioned in the last
episode or I wanted to talk about it
because it was a very interesting heat
thing that I covered that got me
thinking about deeper into this game I
mentioned that a lot of the things I'm
doing don't make sense
you know I'm jumping to conclusions that
I wouldn't ordinarily think about and in
all honesty I think that's a good thing
because the game somatically it's all
about what's going on inside your mind I
mean this whole game see why did that
door open by itself it doesn't make
sense it's not supposed to be like that
because the theme of the game is that
your mind is playing tricks on you or
that you know you can't trust your own
mind so I'm wondering if the things
about this game that are leaping to
assumptions and things aren't making
sense and things are making connections
that they aren't supposed to make is
because this is all not real the game is
leaving you clues of the story of where
we are is leaving you clues that this is
not supposed to be happening right now
none of this is supposed to be happening
so everyone around me is also part of
the same thing that whatever it was
called stem or whatever that whole deal
is all about like the experimentation of
the mind now we're gonna find out more
about that later I imagine but I hope so
hi there how you doing you look good
you're never looked better okay so I'm
fooling those I need to figure out how
to get back into my inventory again
ah God buttons buttons where are you
babe okay V whoa whoa when did I get
that no when the hell did I get that
okay I want that gun onto my number one
the double-barreled shotgun on my two
that on three parts whoa it's hard to
change bull poison bolt it's got a
little brain on it that's adorable what
the hell does that do
oh do I want incendiary I don't wanna I
like the little brain it's a door a ball
okay so that's there can I put that on
for I don't think I have what I need to
shoot that but that's a medical kit
throw up put that on for information
large syringe medical kit I've got some
things that I don't remember getting and
I I don't know if I missed something on
the cutscene there but either way so I'm
gonna get back into this and I'm gonna
play this very carefully from now on
because I want to make sure that I get
to everything because I want to not miss
anything because a lot of people were
saying that I was going through things
and overlooking things once again I
playing very dark so it's pretty dark to
me so I'm not able to see everything
that's going on and oh hello there how
are you doing
should I burn you I have a feeling like
I should burn you I'm just gonna turn my
light off first
I guess I should totally just walk right
into the doorway that opens up for me oh
oh that's how it's gonna be I see we
took a thematic shift very quickly here
but I knew I loved the eye I know that
some people been saying that the
graphics of the game aren't very good
but I don't know where that's coming
from the graphics of this game are
phenomenal look at all the detail that's
put into the game there's so much my new
detail around here that's just
astronomical and a lot of the stuff in
the game tells a story about what's
going on I think I'd prefer to keep my
axe is probably a one-shot deal like the
torch but still it would kill something
oh hi
hi what the hell okay then like I said
this game took a thematic shift very
quickly
oh grenade that can't be good I
shouldn't have that I'm supposed to try
to be very careful about this game I
don't know how much this game is action
and how much it's not okay so penny I
can't break that ha okay not everything
can be broken apparently like I don't
know how much of this game is supposed
to be running gun action but I'm
assuming that hello-o
disarming a bomb I don't want to disarm
a bomb stopping the needle in the blue
zone within one rotation will disarm the
trap disarming the trap yields parts to
me well okay I'll just inject this into
my arm I'm fine it was just an explosion
what the hell I had like no time to
react okay I think I saw a brain goop
outside here just grab that real quick
and though I'll go back inside because I
think I was supposed to go upstairs yeah
at least back outside I'm gonna go back
in I'm gonna go upstairs there's a lot
of secret nooks and crannies around here
I mean I want to be careful but I also
want to move through this relatively
quickly and I'm not I'm not gonna try to
disarm a bomb again because number one
you guys said that they didn't need to
disarm everything just in case I want to
leave traps for the other guys cuz I
don't think that I can set traps myself
but I can op it oh there's another one
I'm gonna leave that there is I'm pretty
sure I can crawl under that and then I'm
gonna leave stuff for other people to
fall onto so that's good that's all good
I'm glad that this is all happening so
clean
okay more of those this is much better
with the mouse and keyboard by the way I
got to admit the the game oh god no what
oh god no what huh who said that
somebody hiding in the closet and gonna
be me for damn sure
who was that whoa what is that oh it's a
swinging body
there are a lot no that's a blanket okay
there are a lot of nuances to this game
but seriously it's amazing how much
detail is put into this how do I get out
okay how do i what
okay I figured out how to drop something
but that's not what I wanted to do okay
who the hell is there it's another human
being Allah who's there
no don't shoot I'm not one of them I'm a
doctor Marcelo Jimenez you were in the
ambulance before crashed right yes we're
lucky to be alive usually anyone are my
patient Lester day I saw him running up
ahead but come this way don't tell me
what to do I'll be as loud as I want to
be coz i'm marga blah yourself okay
seven things chased me all the way into
the village - they're all over the place
they indeed are and they look tasty
delicious food okay oh well that's
convenient any to shoot our way through
well the other gets the gate open oh no
the one with the gun oh so I get the job
of luring do I fine why do I have to do
this stupid job
okay so wait where to go do I have to do
something here hello doctor wait you
need to explain some things you were
actually in that hospital you know
what's going on here why is the crank on
the terrace you will need to operate it
if I'm to past I can't see you the
camera doesn't work that way trying my
best this thing okay oh now I get to
match the spacebar oh oh did you get
nailed by those spikes oh I'm sorry man
I wouldn't know I would have tried to do
something if I had known oh wait a
minute what you're going down there wow
you're a braver than I thought you were
okay then so do I oh oh oh he's the
distraction okay yeah it's good well
why'd you throw it away and get himself
killed
yeah of course he is okay so he's going
what am i spoke a know what he
disappeared he just vanished
okay uh all right then well he's screwed
what do I do
what is that hello ha ha I don't know if
that's quiet or anything but
wait a minute is that the sound of the
dude oh that is so the dude in the
beginning of the game ah party hard
chainsaw man that's totally that dude
isn't it ok so I need to find a way to
him or what I need to avoid him I don't
exactly know what I'm supposed to do
it's not very clear that bottle just
fell down the alcoholic ghost just
dropped his bottle what oh hey oh no no
no no no no no no no no ok I got a one
axe with somebody's name on it if I just
can point the right direction err
Naughton be like a toch whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what are
you doing what the hell you came right
to me you don't know I'm here
don't know yet I guess
whoa whoa Jesus goddamn I didn't even
notice you were there Jesus did you come
from dude well he's got a gun I could
just there we go a little bit better on
the gun that's much better than with the
gamepad I apologize for my poor
performance before but I'm actually out
of ammo right now okay
so I did not expect them to be coming up
here owes nothing to Robert could really
do so I'm gonna get another bottle and I
try to be a bit more stealthy about this
okay so I guess I go down this way and
then I'm gonna go around go try to find
chainsaw man for one reason or another
I'm just thinking that it would announce
his presence with his moaning and
roaring such that oh god not another one
I do not like the bombs can i yes thank
you very much not quite like alien
isolation that I can only go a certain
way and wait when did I get 8900 brain
juice that is a lot more brain juice oh
these frickin bombs man why why why who
put all this here none of this really
makes sense in that you know there's
like a technology discrepancy this is
like a old rustic town and suddenly
there's bombs everywhere it's like a war
zone around here why what is with that I
don't like music boxes why so many weird
noises going on oh okay
God you don't need to startle me like
that she's gone who's gone who is she
what is this Journal of Sebastian Caston
loz december 2014 first day is detective
my new partner Mira Hansen is a real
firecracker tenacious and no-nonsense my
kind of woman but I've got to watch it
around her she almost caught me checking
out her ass today
hahaha because I'm a rookie cop with sex
on the line whoa
all right then I guess I'll go into the
place with all the bugs I mean if this
wasn't a dead giveaway that this all
isn't real like very obviously we're all
trapped in our own minds each and every
one of us we're like in a dream together
and I think my guess my guess is that
we're all in a dream together because
we're all in this we were all in the
ambulance we all fell but this is my
mind this is inside my own head this is
where I have my own little sanctuary so
like this is my separate area compared
to everything else that's my guess as
far as what this goes but I imagine that
the story's gonna be a lot deeper than
that in these or maybe these jail cells
are everyone else's mines there were
four people in that ammos there's four
cells here does that ring any bells here
hey babe what the saving thing okay bye
what can i what are you doing am I
supposed to check out your butt but wait
oh I get to go behind the scenes huh
well then I guess I'll follow you
because I trust you implicitly listen I
got a chainsaw man who wants to have a
rave party with me okay where are we go
where are you taking me yeah seriously
where are you doing I don't like this
much you don't need to talk much okay
well this is normal like how close the
camera is really lets me see my flaws or
my perfection let's turn that off no
need for that whoa yeah do you have a
key like this I think so
well I can't see what the hell camera
really really camera god I don't know
what it is about whoa whoa what is that
what is that
yes oh yes please I don't have an agony
crossbow though I I wouldn't fire yours
I know come back whenever you need to
Wow thanks lady so I guess I could open
any of them all mysteries okay so what
about all this weapons inside my own
mind
pretty cool huh cool okay Oh a map whoa
okay I get it I get it
oh this is so cool this is like my
detective office in here oh this is
awesome there's a lot more to this like
everything in here is telling a story
that's good about the environment
telling a story I've been talking with a
lot of people about actual game
development and looking into like the
intricacies of it and like you know
egoraptor has good series with C colitis
talking to very about the intricacies of
game design and he told me an
interesting thing like that his some of
his sequel itis especially the Megaman
one is shown in like game design classes
because it touches on really good topics
and he knows his stuff okay so I need to
upgrade my shiznit upgrade I got a lot
more than I did before so I don't want
to upgrade I know I got my mu a MA
so life got three seconds of sprint
three seconds that's all this guy can do
that is just annoying okay syringe
recovery I don't know what that means
more firepower damage that's pretty good
fire rate don't need that I need to be
very careful about my image accuracy I
leveled that up doesn't need much but I
could use it
ooh critical strike Wow Oh instantly
killing an enemy with ad job because it
doesn't always happen now that might be
good I say more accuracy no no I'm with
mouse and keyboard now I'll do a little
better so I like the idea of critical
strikes whoa I would rather kill him
with one shot than waste ammo so that's
probably good I don't know if that means
everything can die with one shot but I'm
just gonna go with that okay handgun
ammunition what yeah I can't carry that
much okay so since handguns are gonna be
my main go-to thing I mean
upgrade that first I may not be
upgrading the right thing first but this
is my best inclination so forgive me if
I am totally off topic here and I think
that'll be it for now well I won't be
reloading that much okay I'm gonna save
the rest for my next step oh I injected
juice into my brain that's really
helpful for me let me go wash out my
eyeballs I'll be just fine okay so I
need to get back into the real world now
that was a really important thing that
was really cool and what's with the bugs
the bugs are also gotta be a clue like
all of this has got to be a clue as to
what is going on there's so many bugs so
many bugs zamnesia trying to move a
building oh they're all hiding that
corner look bloggers Rooney's okay so we
need to finish by the doctor died a long
time ago because like where's the
detective and got mauled to death by
everyone okay so I'm gonna take a bottle
and I want to approach this very calmly
and quietly yes please let's turn this
off let's be sneaky about this and let's
go to where we needed to go okay so I
don't know if I have a map ring oh god
damn it I'm back in the friggin
beginning of all I was supposed to go
here first or something huh oh is that
gonna kill me oh oh that is viciously
thank you dr. Frankenstein okay there's
a guy up there I think I needed to go
over yeah here he was okay so I remember
role rawr rawr rawr mangry rawr rawr
rawr okay so there's a man in here maybe
I can get even with him or maybe I'm
supposed to say hi to him maybe I'm
supposed to reason with him Breyer oh
there's another bomb so I tried to
disarm it probably not that would be for
the worst okay line up there I could
burn those things that would be handy
what
no I wanted to break those not my bottle
of booze I don't know if I can climb
this ladder without that going off yep
that's bad uh okay here we go
foo I do not like you I do not like you
a lot I do not like you at all
okay is he up here
where are the heck is he oh I'm going
higher than where am I go high
were you okay whoa that's a whoa that's
a big mm hell yeah all this stuff
what are you can I break you whoa hey
now I'm an all-star get my game on
let's play yeah I see I got a thing I
think I remember a comment saying that I
could break those oh there is hey buddy
oh no oh no you're all chained up oh no
is that mine I don't know how you got
here considering that you're in the
hospital but I see a chainsaw
I want to chainsaw whoa okay let's
disarm this first chunk okay so I got
these parts and I'm assuming that
they're just for crafting I don't see
any other monsters here so I'm just
gonna assume that I can run around with
reckless abandon something over here
I've got plenty of matches and I know
people said that I didn't need to burn
everything for so that I don't waste
anything another grenade I think much
okay
man I'm already at like 20 minutes that
I've been playing this on I don't feel
like this episode has been going very
long I haven't made a lot of progress I
guess I feel like I've been moving
forward very quickly but I guess I guess
I've just been looping around the same
area for a little bit but that's okay I
want to make sure that I get to
everything because there's so much
detail in this game okay what do I do
here how do I get this open I did not
expect that to work hey can I have that
oh come on
it's right there hey you hey you yo whoa
well what is going on okay that was a
mistake why did I do that
Oh oh god I'm sorry Oh what am i doing
but I don't want to look horrible error
why'd I do this oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh I made the worst mistake possible
what did I do
oh why did I do all of that oh why okay
I needed to take a break I guess but oh
my god this was I couldn't have done
this worse
oh god no
[ __ ] myself so hard why didn't I just
grab the chainsaw and everybody came by
everybody came runnin I didn't have a
chance claws of the Horde is the name of
the chapter here holy balls oh god damn
it do not tell me do not tell me I am
this far back are you [ __ ] me you oh
you have got to be kidding me what are
you kidding me
I cannot be this far back you are
bullshitting me oh [ __ ] me oh god damn
it with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I like screwed myself over because I
didn't know that it was gonna set off
the whole goddamn town I went up the
only the only sphere that didn't have a
way to go afterwards you know what screw
you with your stupid mask and creepy
mask and your gun you're done you're
done you're done just fall over yeah
yeah you're done okay so we are back
I am pologize for that but one of my
biggest pet peeves in all of gaming is
unnecessarily losing progress like I how
would I have not known that that's what
I was supposed to do so I think I need
this ax here to definitely be able to do
this so swap out hitting it with a
bottle of booze is not gonna solve your
problems it solves most of your problems
but not that one why would I want to
burn the piggies I don't yeah okay so I
don't need to do that I'm gonna check
back here just in case there's anything
else I need before I release this guy to
the wolves no okay it seems just like an
empty place so I'm gonna open this up
I'm gonna go through I think I'm gonna
go back up the ladder so that he can't
follow me immediately because I doubt
this guy
hey buddy hey haha we're out we're out
baby route and we're going up we're
going up we're escaping we're ass copy
hey buddy hey you're looking good friend
okay so I don't know if this is gonna
protect me in any way goddamn I'm not
playing with my control but my control
keeps shaking over there I don't know if
that guy can follow me up here and I
don't know if the rest of the town is
gonna be able to know that I'm up here
oh yes they are what the hell I gotta
take him down what do you mean take him
down I don't know how I'm gonna do that
let me try burning this okay so wait
wait a minute wait
hello
oh no you do not I'm out I'm out baby
whoa wait whoa okay not again not again
not a frickin game The Alibi supposed to
be able to do this whoa what what am I
looking at oh hello
Oh goddamn it why why Oh cuz he had a
sniper rifle that's why okay
god dammit you're so wimpy Bereal going
critical
what if I do the grenade those amazingly
effective you burn up you bastard
you to you to you burn you go get burn
Oh God how many are you don't talk
come on blow up already there's one down
down those stairs you lady
all the way down come on kick yeah and
stuff pick up this thing whoa here he
comes
whoa whoa I'm not ready I'm not ready
I'm not ready I'm not ready oh god oh
god oh god oh god where do I go oh how
do I get rid of him what does this do
this just do oh my god I know that did
that oh god oh god use it use it use it
oh god I'm dead oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
please tell me this yes oh my god I am
done I am done so how the hell do I get
away from this guy oh where am i where
am i where am I whoa whoa it's bound to
be a lot of items where I blew everybody
up to a bloody pulp I think I just
dodged stuff yeah yeah here bound to be
a lot of items right here nope just a
few bullets that's apparently in
anyway this guy's gonna get this shotgun
well where is he
Jesus can I just get away from the guy
wait a minute how am I supposed to open
this I don't know oh you figure it out
induce who the hell are you know whom
instead it bear guy yeah I need to burn
you push thank you
where is the guy did I kill the whole
village yet I'm pretty sure I'm close to
killing the whole village here okay what
is that ooh I had if I had that I didn't
get that when I opened the boxes
whoa whoa is he dead yes whoa we numb by
bugs oh now I pick it up why didn't I
just pick it up before well hello
what the hell are you doing here you
want to tell me what's going on with
this stupid place with this thing oh
yeah cuz holding onto it before would
have been a very poor choice on your
behalf I have no idea why I'm even
tolerating this there's just baloney if
you ask me I was under than something
that was supposed to be quiet about this
and then all chaos all the time that's
exactly what we're doing anyway let's
continue on now that I'm completely out
of ammo all right so
okay I couldn't I could have just done
that I could have just done that okay
there's no excuse for that wait yeah
where've you good officer you must take
me with you you did a real good
distracted Castellanos Leslie should be
just ahead it is imperative that we find
him imperative oh thank you for closing
right on me again I guess that explains
why that the whole town took so long but
either way that is all the time I have
for this episode here and that's a
little bit too much patience on my
behalf for getting through theirs I
really don't like it when a game forces
you to go back because you didn't know
any better I don't know why I had to
unload like unlace the guy I couldn't
pick up the chainsaw right there and
there was an explicit use for the
chainsaw that I didn't even know I
needed so it was a disconnect there and
that's the problem on the game design
but either way still fun I'll see how it
goes in the next episode so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
a spear the entrails of the fallen on
their face
[Music]
come back here I got some question for
you
[Music]